So it was
a union roster in actual fact. Oh yes.
When you say you know if you know weren't
there. You know if we were there that day
that they you know call up me in the well
you crossed or hear you call their names
and so you know that this particular day i
happened to be there and we used to play
cards you know put the dime in you've got
to sing songs that the town hall can't say
i just played rummy factually all day
here and now i never at the
traits all in praise or
never wonder you know they
w me because you know what much
casual work in you know in the a.w.
Year and not like in the film and in fact
as he had the wool stores and they have
a ship coming in. You know take will away
well and either start in the dumping
section you know and there
were company when they had
a boat. They'd come in with oil
tins nutcases. Case of the teen
spirit to kerosene thing like
that oil they need to gang
a to you now and. Take you know the
out of the tanks and into tins and no
overseas be. It be tinned overseas in case
and put in the ship and they bring it
here. Sydney and then they take it loaded
onto trucks and the trucks that take it
out of the oil company in
the world come to here have
a big ship and at that. I tell you
it's pretty hard to and say i was used
to you know doing a bit
a navy and work on the bridge. It was
you know i said me self well you know i
thought i should be fit but it was different.
Different muscle years and i tell you
the first couple of days near lift
no bloomin tens of spirit to tend to
a case and course would be living on your
own and when you go on up there be one
here in one go faster you ben. You know
up they go up they go and you'd have to
feel good form i tell you that you know
keeper and how many decks high do they go
with it. Guys they go up to
thirty or forty you know lean
in that they've been with they were out.
Four they will be like ten platforms and
how then shall be out for oil on you
know i do. Yup yup yup. The top and.
Down at the trade hall garden down there
was he. He wasn't involved was he involved
in your union. No no you is involved with
the trade unions you know you so i know
he was
a trade y'all delegate at that mp the mp
because depend on the change union for
their support. Is
a city council but also i notice that he
was also i think the secretary at that
time but he was also chairman of the
disputes committee because i heard his name
mentioned i read the harbour bridge. I'm
not too sure he might i mean you know i
mean i do good. He might have been
a member but he was interested in the
union movement and it was him that had
a meeting about the unemployed and that's
why the unemployed sold them back as
others. You know happened to me i didn't
know that the meat and tell you that you
die happen to be in the room when they
brought the book in and i said no i'm not
lose anything but you know now so i put
my name down and that's what happened and
when you left the bridge. You went back on
store and packing were you on the dole.
Then after the bridge. No i don't
think so. I. I think i got i got
back on dive straight into
the straight into the
stall and packers. And i you know
could got enough casual work to keep me
going till i actually i got a job with
a well company then i would pollute less
your company in nineteen. Thirty five. I
think and i was there for up to 1960 for.
That's where i don't or my best part of
my work was at the shelter and.
fifty fifty odd years for them.
Eight years at least i'm sorry. Twenty
eight twenty eight. Now you know and
then i got kicked out how to retire
when i was sixty. I happened to get
a job i was living that
manly of a time and i got
a job. I'm in the council of the cleaner
office cleaner and i put five years as
office cleaner and when i
became sixty five i had
a retired sixty five of the at the
council. So i've been retired ever since
i think sixty nine live on the pension.
So looking back what was it like. What
you're of impressions looking back at the
time when you were working on the bridge
approach as best thing i can think of that
it was you know me a job well as doing
a thing that was necessary for the state
a large country at large with the bridge.
I thought myself you know been built. You
know
a long while before there and i mean on
the north side and close to it. It meant
a lot to us and those days but i just
before i got the job i got married and
i turned that bad policy to be able to
work. You know fairly when you just start
north. You know yeah. Get down together and
i was quite happy to have the job done
without you know how tough it was and i
don't regret anything that happened. I
happy time i got on all of the men or i
than the gang is alright and i'm quite
happy. Tell me what did you do for
a recreation those days where
do you go when you had
a bit of time off and bit of money
there. Pocket. Two there used to be
around you know around different places
to get in and day out to you know. Go
around you wouldn't get they think by wait
on the paper you have to get around ask
people if they want
a new no they you know. Do you did you
find no did you have no recreation. Do you
not sport is dancing is one of
a hot day is in town. You could or
dickens under the main bar and have
a swim and something like that. You know
and play card mostly wait and wait to get
a job that was
a recreation you know at you anyway.
Dancing so that we weren't much on
that either. And actually you know fit in
with the work it was to try to get there
as i know i would never really it's
a challenge. You know father might have
you know gone if i was that way inclined
but to have two left feet i
mean you can't remember any any
other recreation at that time we had
to play tennis. I used to go down for
a game of tennis no weekend and you know
you have any amusing stories of when you
were working on the bridge you produce. I
can't say oh they're not nothing amusing
you know only i worked with a
chap i thought was amusing he was
a welshman and you'd be always
amused the way you the talk and
he used to say so they let you go. He's
a letter went you know and. Oh
yeah i'd be curious you had
vacuity away. You know the i forget now
exactly but that was one other say and you
know the so they say and let it go. He's
a letter went you know. Do you member any
of the cement mixer crews and yes i am
very pally with
a couple of our drivers. You know chapman
oh my fred smith used to drive the truck
for them and the public works wagon
and what sort of wagons were they all
quite big
a ton as you know and you know neal little
they were you could see me get in any
good. You know spin the truck in
anywhere you know if they have to have
a shed down. They won't have
a way you know as yet when do we need to
out the uprights. You know it and he used
i managed to you know we lose big truck
with the thing it in between these guys you
know take
a lot of skill. I reckon you know
what sort of trucks they were all
ireland i think hadley and white's thing
leyland someone you know and i have
tele with a chap private they are
a lot of private carriers on the job
and people to them are robson and
from craziness. They had trucks on the
job and one other obs and the one they
drive me was the same with me. You work in
the same gang as i was shoveller and the
build up to the calling baldy. Well they're
all because you call the air and no
airline and then about the two only an
hour i can remember their surnames.
There. Because i know you know quite a
lot by their christian names and that's
a long while ago you member around north
sydney area do you member the ferries and
the way the moving of the station. Oh yes
i remember the ferries and the old hunts
and things like that and i i oh i
forgot that you know that i had
a i started off and greengrocers
business and i used to use the used
to use the ferry you
know into la and i'm on
a little lankov at the time and i used to
use the pump to go across and you know
you think you know bird's eye view of the
bridge as you go on over and the place i
lived in greenwich and was you get
a look across the water. You see the
bridge i you know it's all aspects of the
bridge. Actually you
know go up so you have
a little business on the side while you
were working on the richard you know and
after that was when i was out of work i
was about before i started on the bridge
that was only about eighteen or
nineteen i fail and i and that
deal in the time. How do you go with the
business. Oh i would make your ports and
tell you to be tough. You know nobody any
money and i think that time you know
people about what a lot
for nothing and they had
a mate and. He was i mean out of work
and we had to go the fish market we buy
a case of fish you get a filleted and we
go up the north shore line and we'd have
a nice white and then we'll try and of white
cloth over the wall walk. You'd spend
your money and walk all day they affairs
and fire and the end they are your fate x
is even about two and six for the day
you had to be keen. You know today
. You have to be keen. I
battled i tell you. Do you
live down lanka charedim but i would just
like down there when there's that time.
Oh granny beautiful but it's right on the
river. The bottom part you know in the
top other top part of greenish
looks down but all down
a very quiet flat when i was
here and they live and up
a bit down and i went mad shop for yourself
to go to crow's nest to do her job in
the most shops you know crone out and used
to walk across the wheels and can't get
work at us. I think i think it's a change
that are going to settle in we had
a bus going from glenys to
point to some lenders and
then we had the oil or oil workers at the
bottom of greenedge road and usually in
the early part used to be
a lot of traffic that i mean you know not
going to or for you to walk up the street
and you know what your first move there
because of the because their oil company.
No i don't know it's as a wife live there
and i lived that long of all that's
a couple all dump further one water.
Further up the river like and when i got
married. We started house in have in 1926.
We start of the house in in place and got
you know new cottage in any trade not far
away from almost mother play and if you're
ever what you paid rent in then there's
a thirty two and six i pay. How much would
you pay for all doubt for £4 i think
it was actually you know too much you
know i say when i moved to manly in
nineteen thirty five. I only
paid fifteen shillings.
And wages were a bit i think
of work and you know wages
a bit higher than you know for the full
time found no today. That that's you know
and when you were on the bridge was it the
same pay for £4 all the way through and
there's more. And if there's more i think
in fiji i think we've got about eight. We
have a rationed a we have a
ration if we i'm. Three days
a week. I think it was on food only. On
the bridge on the beach approach here.
In time for real bad. And then they gradually
put you on for more days of the week
when things got better. We don't full
time when you know when they will get no
finish an uplift rage and i was lucky that
at the finish. I got kept on quite the
majority and got put off you know when the
bridge opened that i you know the job
the gang we were doing the gardening
work their grass and all of the you know
bottom part of the bridge and the waterfront
down that way. Doing up the streets
and things like that and
eventually i. I got
i had to go look for more different
feels that i ended up and i end up in
a regular job at the finish and go. Can
you tell something about the casual.
Store and packer's job from the point of
view of the wool stores exactly did they
have
a pool of casual labour all the time they
have many current many permanents i know
i was all stores. Oh they have quite a few
but nothing like the staff they've got
a handle on the seasons on. And when
the spurs are all stores is concerned.
Nina as soon as the season starts. Well
that's when they start to employ casual
labour and if they there's
men casual work as
a follow other particular stores up and
they report to see if they can get
a job if they're out of work and if the
wheels stores can't get anybody to
approach them for
a job they just ring up the wall stall
the stall and back as union and you all
still and takers union jenny got
a good list of men looking for
a job and so they sent
around and this applies in
a lot of what they call someone
up gang want to say after
a sale of all there's two hundred and
hundreds of bales it's been opened up in the
top and been speculated by the buyer and
the wolves will be put back into the in
the bales and sign up and that's what they
call the sowers sewing up game and these
chaps floyd on a casual basis and
they might only get one or two days
a week and they go from store to store.
Wherever the sales on but another part of
the wool game is the dumping will dumping
when i say they dumped all the shipping
and in this particular
case. The conditions are
a lot of harder. Not a lot harder
work and in lots of cases there's
a lot of machine as men working dumps
dumping machines and they need experience
workers and so on the job last longer and
when these people get
a job they start off and do it and
if the job if the ship is sailing
a certain time might knesset say they work
all day work all day and all night too.
And these chaps are on
a fair fair wage that they get because the
same rate. I saw at the saddest day. So
is up get but it's more along the job. And
if you can see the distance out and at the
end of a one ship. You can earn quite
a lot of money and it's just like
the wharfies. In those days was
a still dave and that's why they would
say they work a ship they get a job on
a boat and they work so much overtime and
work all night and if you work all night
. Well natalie and
that's a break. They get
a fair whack of money and. As far
as i was concerned them day i
was prepared to work because after i
finish the job. I know there were no other
work that go to and i could
recuperate fool. I think we sell for
the casual workers and entitled to all the
money they can get because when you're
out looking for a job you you're not
paid and they're think and that's only
a very very tired you've if you
work one block and you know into
a couple of place and ask if they want
their labor and they say you know i do it
you get tired very quick and decide that
and and tell me how long did you have to
be off work in order to qualify for the
dole. I thought night i think those days so
you could pick up a couple of days
work and that it is qualify you for
a fortnight from getting the dole.
Now you know if you had a sign
a declaration that you never earned certain
amount of time that your work there was
an amount of money or do
you have any trouble with
a dull inspectors on that sort of thing.
Now i now know i never cheated. Not much
anyway. You know come across
inspectors at that time
know gaza and. Do you ever get in
a position where you faced eviction from
you know for me has always treated or i
lie. And the mother in law holds out at
one stage mother all they'll be out and i
played
a half and one landlord and i. When i
moved from granny to i owed him. $5 and
. I moved i said i'd pay more and when i
went oh man. The only way i haven't i
would have a win in the no
lottery and i won a ten. I think
a lot and i said he. The fiver in the us
quite happy in the very thought he'd ever
get the five aleck.